17 to 20 live bodies when join these
drills so guys get rest Plumbly couldn't
get the milsat pants here comes one to
be able to do this rebound
coast-to-coast I mean he's driving past
guards getting all the way to the rim
like 23 and the level of commitment that
this guy is shown
[Applause]
and it's nearly chipped it in Rondo
quickly comes the other way floats it up
to McGee McGee finds James to the
bastard his draft class miss most of the
summer rehabilitating rather LeBron
Lonzo as he found LBJ problem with that
is if guys like LeBron can feel your
body and know which side he can spin on
really a struggle
[Applause]
fortunate very gotta start making
buckets bounce this blob though the
bounce makers lead is six
we need another one in team one the
Wooden Award
oh sorry buddy oh this guy I like this
mindset turns down the jump up puts his
head down attacks cover I can't get
there caldwell-pope little bit Stein but
he still came up with it
and then LeBron for long so that's just
sick very nice hammers at all for these
second-chance points good play by Rondo
now we've got a four on one
[Applause]
makers will run with Lonzo the past 18
LeBron James wonderful assist from Lonzo
vault worst enoch enhancement there's
suppose they get it back and it's
stripped now kuzmin's got it he puts it
up
[Applause]
Lakers lead down by one second free
throw miss good effort by goos it's
stripped after the rebound puts it back
and then LeBron cleaned it up bounces
Lonzo protect pass gonna get right back
[Applause]
look at the first one where he creates
for LeBron and LeBron hammers one and
it's just a good job of knowing where
LeBron is going to be cutting after that
secondary defender in 2012 and 2013
[Applause]
[Music]
not down Josh hard good offensive
rebound here open wound aside says here
see if you can make it whoa that is nice
respect the non shooter coming off good
wheat hand contested shots and he makes
it winning games drive itself lucious
[Applause]
17 first half points for LeBron James
they definitely JaVale shoot a slip
screen and just rent it in front of the
rim
[Applause]
don't blabber on James bail out a couple
of blocks the other night again one of
the top shot blockers in the entire NBA
throw it down the assistant who's
guarding someone that's got the hand
like that say enough about to change the
direction off the dribble scam shows you
that first one Isaacson always says
where did he go we went to the rim
and he finished left the rim then the
next trip down little spin contact use
the left flex yep we know you strong
[Music]
[Applause]
will show that tap by Tyson that went to
Casey P and LeBron says Isaac get out of
the way I said hey no problem I won't
stay in front of it anyhow as he lets
LeBron go to the rim Isaac oh by the way
with five
for Dallas 10 for LeBron
twelve well they see they've always done
that play and LeBron has just handed it
off the brand that weirdness there's to
play but they anticipated the handoff
and it didn't happen at all you need to
know dodge X comes up short for his
Lakers hola he'll to me
yeah he's one for nine throw it down
he's all alone and again it's LeBron at
the rim disap knows his points are right
at the rim about that breaker who's had
it in the middle II jumped and lost
control of it for a minute but did while
in the air was able to tap it that's
legal and we know what LeBron does with
it that's definitely he's old before
still in fifteen points good balanced by
the Lakers that's a good pass to twos
but they're gonna take it LBJ
substitution 13-6 runs since LeBron
minted back into this ball he takes it
strong and long
[Applause]
lines up by the statute he'll get a free
throw running down heel
number 23 you are clear for takeoff then
that's his second rebound LeBron James
and control of the basketball
backing up Oleg he loves this matchup
that's where you've got to send that
secondary defender to LeBron much faster
than that's alive and with all they got
five and a half minutes to go let's see
if the Lakers can play with some energy
now James that's an OG play split two
defenders and then say here I come
take this really picked up the energy
for the team in the last couple of
minutes started off with that play down
the middle on the inbounds picked off by
Jambo James all the way only the second
bucket for long toe ball 2 of 7 from the
field run autumn at the top of the key
shoot right over him for another three
on I know Houston runners a true added
jam by LeBron James
[Applause]
and that's what they came to see up
holding their feet when he threw that
one down if it LeBron comes down and
look change direct straight down the gut
and hammers down a two-handed flush job
[Applause]
and he just says okay I'll just split a
couple of defenders and then go up and
get to finish his Turner with the foul
and LeBron with the three-point
opportunity from downtown are the
windows down to 11 Bourbons pass picked
off jeez a great play recognition that's
right by the young fella throwing the
ball look the beautiful open when the
Lakers are at their best in the lack of
shooting he throws the crowd against the
Lakers back to 1:13 108 that's good
another looked at the LeBron blame where
he got into the wall cuz it was a jump
shot
[Applause]
Mendelson wasting no time now you know
he told Kristen Ledlow that hammer at
all here's curry for checking the
dribble flips it ahead and broke it up
Durant for Wade Walker back this way to
set it and here's off the backboard the
old teammates back-to-back champion
Miami Heat
we used to see this the Cleveland olive
could still he's among the leaders in
steals point lead for Houston
[Applause]
in stature
[Music]
yeah somewhere tape backing LeBron
that's what worthy used to do each team
with over 30 points the 325 to play is
to get another look at the pass from Rob
to Ian Clark for three no good long
rebound Kuzma James goes to the
contestant with the side missed it
batted out to Rondo a little bit of
resistance there at the rim by the lake
a ten-to-one run by the Lakers 1814
Milwaukee in front gentle T with six
points to this first Jam but a gorgeous
feed from Ingram there's that length
again that time being used on the glass
do you see the reach talking about that
is incredible
[Applause]
certainly can
first Duncan the king is in the house
and it's worthy of multiple looks and he
fits perfectly with this group
James accelerate
[Applause]
Milwaukee is a Kingston friend and
Reggie Bullock take it away defense to
offense three on one timeout the timeout
nice
what possession if you get another look
at the last basket as LeBron goes up and
hammers one in the third quarter this
group used a lot of energy to come back
in $23 James slams at home do they have
enough left in the tank Jane Jetson side
and a nice finish their first second
field goal now Williams with a rebound
[Music]
pass to James throws it down good set up
from Wayne Bunny's gonna get right back
Kiku's after they did now he's making
someone removed though
[Music]
BJ just clicked over 20 second ago I
turn over ahead of the package the bar
here he goes did he put on his [ __ ] with
that would mr. Carlos camp
there's the turnover and Cousteau's it
out of head and LeBron off the bounce
get this they're gonna get a second
opportunity
taken over by the Lakers here's Josh
Hart
[Applause]
Oh Oh Showtime he gets in the open court
and does this for the Lakers played only
two games able to take all the way it's
listening he's a good shooter though
he's never happy with a particular shot
this is what in there just out fought
him for the ball beautifully LeBron able
to take to the hoop the Lakers down by 7
[Music]
that's three threes have 12 is a tune
around underneath McHugh get spliced
watt it stays in Caruso down the middle
[Applause]
basically what coach ticket coaches do
they coax according to the talent to
throw it down plenty of time to shoot on
the clock he's going one-on-one gonna
pull up on its way short rebounder Rondo
caldwell-pope I'd set that side of the
LeBron in 20 or 25 games but he's played
in all 13 games in March he's back right
down the middle downhill on a slab of a
spectacular view the bounce pass pity
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content